Speaker 1: Lauren Boebert has now repeatedly
prayed for the death of President Joe Biden.
Tonight is the State of the Union address. Joe
Biden will address the nation. I will be streaming
live on youtube, twitch and facebook starting a
little after 8 p.m. eastern and i hope that you'll
join me so we can see what joe biden has to say
and if and whether he unveils new policy tonight,
it actually would make sense for Secret Service
to take extra care when screening certain people
tonight. And one of those people is Lauren
Boebert. I'm going to play a clip for you of
Lauren Boebert at some church. She does these
church appearances and she is praying for the
death of Joe Biden here. Now, I know when you
hear it, you might say it's sort of ambiguous.
It's really not ambiguous if you understand the
Bible verses. So let's listen to what Lauren
Boebert had to say and then go from there.
Speaker 4: God said. He was the provider.
I know that Jesus said that he that we would
be blessed, but I just don't know about this
month. And Jesus is right there at the table with
you. Same. What kind of conversation is this?
Why are you talking like
this? And why are you sad?
Jesus. Don't you know we're out of money? Come
and sit. They shut everything down. Joe Biden,
President We don't know.
Unidentified: What to do, Lord.
That's all right.
Speaker 4: We pray for
our presidents. You know, it says. Let his days
be few and another take his office. That's why I
filed the articles of impeachment for Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, you might say, David, with
all due respect, that's pretty ambiguous. It's not
ambiguous if you understand the full context of
what she is quoting the verse that Lauren Boebert
references, there is Psalm 1098, and it is clearly
about praying for the death of an enemy in office
because she quoted let his days be few and let
another take his office and then the rest of it
is let his children be fatherless and his wife
a widow. You don't become a widow just because
your husband gets impeached. As she talks about,
you become a widow because your husband dies.
Your children become fatherless, not because
you're impeached, but because you die. And Lauren
Boebert also, I can't believe I'm using this term,
but she preached this message in June as well.
Speaker 4: Praise the Lord. I hope that
blesses somebody.
Unidentified: But I.
I do want.
Speaker 4: You to
know I pray for our president. Psalm 1098
says May his days be few and another take
his office.
Speaker 1:
Hallelujah. Yeah. So that's exactly the same
thing. She knows exactly what the verses. She
knows the context. What we're talking about
here is praying for the death of Joe Biden.
At minimum, every single one of
these places where she's preaching
needs to lose its tax exempt status. That's
an absolute minimum. And we've talked about
that before. But there are people like
Lauren Boebert going to tonight's State
of the Union who should be screened very,
very closely by Secret Service. That is
what is insane. The calls are coming from inside
the house. Now, one defense that I saw made is
she's speaking statistically. Joe Biden is 80
years old. Show 80 year olds don't tend to live
much longer. Well, if you if you really want to
play that game right. And we can do that, you
can look at the Social Security life expectancy
tables. These are actuarial tables. And if you
are 80 years old, this is from 2019. I don't know
that the numbers have been updated since then,
but based on these are the numbers used this
year from 2019, if you an 80 year old male,
you have a 5.6% chance of dying in the following
year and you are expected to live another 8.4
years. As an 80 year old male in the U.S. in 2019.
So for those staying saying this is just about
letting father time take his course or whatever
the case may be, you may be disappointed to know
the actuarial numbers on which Social Security
is based. Disgusting woman An absolute shame
and embarrassment is Lauren Boebert. And I really
hope that Secret Service is going to keep a close
eye on her tonight. We're going to take a quick
break. Make sure you are subscribed to the show
on YouTube at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show. Very powerful live stream coming up tonight.